bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
l'émission qui revient sur l'actualité
économique locale on commence tout de
suite avec les titres quels seront les
véhicules de demain c'était la question
posée par le colloque sur la mobilité
2.0 à satori ce mardi un événement
présidéré par Frédéric Cuvillier le
ministre chargé des transports
portes ouvertes dans les centres de
formation pour adultes de l'AFPA
l'association souhaite former à des
métiers en manque de personnel
izum sur les marchés des tablettes
numériques un produit qui marche bien
vont-elles remplacer les classiques PC
réponse dans notre dossier de la semaine
et puis nous parlerons du métier
d'artisan boucher un secteur qui cherche
à recruter nous recevons sur ce sur
notre plateau max thébaudin bonsoir vous
êtes bouché au Chesnay vous étiez
également le président du jury lors de
la présélection au concours du meilleur
apprenti bouché de France nous verrons
se dérouler le déroulé de cette épreuve
dans un instant mais avant on passe aux
infos économiques de la semaine
développer les transports intelligents
une bataille technologique et économique
pour le gouvernement c'était d'ailleurs
le thème d'un colloque organisé par le
ministre chargé des sports à Versailles
satori des images de Patrick Jacques de
Dixmude
une navette qui se déplace sans
chauffeur un véhicule de simulation pour
s'entraîner à l'écoconduite autant de
projets pour préparer la mobilité de
demain une mobilité 2.0 le 11 février le
ministre des Transports avait rassemblé
à satori partenaire public et privé pour
évoquer les stratégies de développement
de ce secteur l'occasion de découvrir
les projets en cours cette voiture
électrique par exemple a priori rien de
particulier sauf qu'à l'intérieur le
chauffeur ne touche ni aux pédales ni au
volant dans l'idée je suis juste en
train de sélectionner la vitesse et en
fait
je ne touche à rien le véhicule se
déplace tout seul pour le moment la
législation française ne permet pas de
commercialiser un véhicule automatique
mais le gouvernement l'affirmé les
choses devraient évoluer ce véhicule
n'est donc qu'un prototype dans sa
version finale ce clavier devrait être
remplacé par un écran tactile
un peu redondant entre la détection de
marquage par la caméra
et un système de localisation très
précise avec le GPS RTK le véhicule a
une trajectoire de référence et
ensuite il va calculer les forces à
exercer sur le volant pour effectuer
cette trajectoire de référence autre
véhicule intelligent cette voiture
électrique et automatique accessible aux
personnes en fauteuil roulant ici ce
drone permet d'assurer l'inspection des
infrastructures routières au niveau des
transports publics on a créé ce bus
hybride il fonctionne avec un moteur
thermique mais peut également
fonctionner en mode tout électrique le
but est de pouvoir avoir un système qui
soit qui parcourt toute la journée
depuis le matin tôt jusqu'à le soir tard
en mode électrique sans avoir à
transporter énormément de batterie le
but est de pouvoir transporter le juste
nécessaire pour aller de zone de
recharge en zone de recharge le réseau
de transport d'Île-de-France le STIF
pourrait être intéressé ils ont choisi
de ne plus financer diesel et de
s'équiper en véhicules plus propres le
gouvernement y voit également un enjeu
national
qui représentent
4,5 milliards d'euros avec plus de
plusieurs centaines d'entreprises et
start-up souvent entre 500 et un millier
d'entreprises 45 000 emplois mais emploi
direct avec autant de dizaines de
milliers d'emplois qui en découlent et
puis la perspective de demain pour la
filière automobile il a ainsi annoncé la
création d'une fabrique de la mobilité
2.0 qui regroupe industriels acteurs
publics start-up et organismes de
recherche le gouvernement annonce
également le déploiement expérimental de
3000 véhicules intelligents sur les
routes françaises dès cette année
et cette fabrique de la mobilité 2.0
dont on parlait dans ce reportage
s'appelle vdcom la contraction de
véhicules décarbonée communicants et sa
mobilité un partenariat était signé avec
l'Agence nationale de la recherche
notamment pour le financement on compte
au total 35 partenaires publics comme
l'UVSQ ou le Conseil général mais
également privé comme Renault ou Valeo
un institut qui voudrait être leader en
Europe un projet ambitieux comme nous
l'explique Louis Gallois le commissaire
général à l'investissement
va être doté de moyens financiers
considérables 330 millions sur 9 ans les
investissements d'avenir y apportent 54
millions les industriels en apportant
119 le conseil général en apporte 20
bref tout le monde s'est mis ensemble
pour constituer un
centre de de recherche technique de
d'industrialisation qui réunit toute
l'industrie vous avez en France c'est
pas si facile que ça me faire travailler
les gens ensemble l'accouchement a été
difficile mais maintenant le bébé est là
et il est il est beau il faut le faire
grandir
l'AFPA ouvrez aujourd'hui la porte de
ses centres de formation un peu partout
en France pour ceux qui ne la
connaissent pas encore il s'agit de une
association qui propose des formations
pour adultes nous nous sommes rendus à
Élancourt un site spécialisé dans le
tertiaire administratif malgré la crise
des débouchés existent un reportage
réalisé avec Étienne Dang
une journée pour changer de vie c'est ce
que proposer aujourd'hui l'AFPA un
organisme de formation pour adulte
entendée par là changer de vie
professionnelle par tout en France les
différents centres de cette association
ont ouvert leurs portes comme ici à
Élancourt car en pleine période de crise
économique et de hausse du chômage ont
compté encore en France 300 000 emplois
non pourvu quel secteur recrute quelle
formation sont disponibles sous quelles
conditions autant de questions
auxquelles Dalila et les autres
visiteurs chercher des réponses cette
mère de famille a arrêté de travailler
pour élever ses enfants aujourd'hui elle
peine à retrouver un emploi elle
souhaiterait intégrer ici une formation
de secrétaire assistante
je reste dans ma branche
initiale mais par contre reprendre une
formation pour pouvoir être plus
performante en informatique
l'association a repéré 13 secteurs
d'activités sous tension de l'industrie
aéronautique et spatiale à l'économie
numérique en passant par l'hôtellerie
l'idée est donc d'aiguiller les
demandeurs d'emploi 70% du public de
l'AFPA pour qu'il réponde aux demandes
des entreprises la valeur ajoutée en
fait des formations AFPA c'est
effectivement l'insertion nos stagiaire
c'est le fait que 6 à 7 stagiaires sur
soit réintégré dans le monde
professionnel la l'utilité sociale de
l'AFPA et à ce niveau là
80% de la formation est pratique ici par
exemple un plateau technique recréer un
domicile et permet de s'entraîner au
métier d'assistant de vie en conditions
réelles en Île-de-France on compte ces
sites AFPA ouvert à tous certaines
formations peuvent être rémunérées
le MAAF le concours du meilleur apprenti
de France donne chaque année la chance
aux jeunes apprentis de dévoiler leurs
talents le 12 février c'était au tour
des apprentis bouchés de tenter de se
qualifier pour l'étape régional neuf
candidats pour une seule place un
reportage réalisé avec Élodie moine
devenir le meilleur apprenti de France
un titre dont rêve tous les jeunes
artisans et parmi eux ces neuf apprentis
bouchés ils viennent des Yvelines de
l'Essonne et du Val d'Oise pour tenter
de se sélectionner pour l'étape
régionale pour Mathieu les débuts n'ont
pas été évidents
de couteau dans mon travail c'est un
petit peu gâché mon travail quoi car
c'est sur le désossage qu'ils seront
principalement notés les désossas c'est
une opération qui consiste à enlever les
eaux on les sent tout ce qui est gras et
muscles de côté tout simplement et le
l'art de métier de la viande consiste à
faire un des dosages à blanc ce qu'on
appelle Ablon c'est à dire on laisse que
l'os qui brille au total il leur faudra
préparer quatre pièces de viande agneau
bœuf et volaille
le métier de boucher est l'un des rares
secteurs qui recrutent la masse
salariale a augmenté de 26% en 3 ans
mais une victoire au concours reste une
ligne importante à rajouter sur son CV
c'est pour essayer de montrer qu'on peut
faire quelque chose qu'on arrive à faire
quelque chose dans ce métier ça ouvre
des portes le concours aussi de réussir
le concours ça permet d'ouvrir des
portes vers de futurs patrons et ça
permet aussi on va pas se le cacher à
négocier son salaire de c'est un atout
en plus c'est comme un diplôme en plus
dans n'importe quel autre métier
Matthieu y voit également une
valorisation du métier
de brut comme il y en a beaucoup
de la finesse quoi s'il y a des décors
des choses que on nous apprend là-bas
comme faire des roses des navets dans
des carottes tout ça car après avoir
désossé épluché la viande il faudra la
préparer et la décorer mais attention un
beau rendu n'est pas synonyme de
victoire le jugement est fait sûrement
sur la pratique du travail c'est pas
forcément la décoration parce que il
peut y avoir des des jeunes qui vont se
former sur des décorations mais la base
du métier bien sûr c'est un petit plus
mais la base de métier c'est le travail
de la viande le jury va noter les
candidats à chaque étape après 4h30
d'épreuve voici le résultat les
candidats peuvent se détendre en
compagnie de leur famille ou de leur
maître d'apprentissage
l'heure du verdict a sonné tout
s'attendent avec impatience le résultat
déception pour Théo qui échoue à la
cinquième place execo avec Mathieu et
c'est finalement un candidat d'Essonne
qui emporte la mise une belle surprise
pour ce candidat qui a hésité jusqu'au
dernier moment à participer à cette
épreuve il pense savoir ce qu'il a fait
gagner
avoir envie aussi de réussir et il faut
pas lâcher quoi ne rien lâcher c'est
l'un des conseils de son actuelle patron
il a très vite décelé le potentiel de
son apprenti ses capacités dès le départ
je les ai sentis
à travers sa à travers son travail et
puis la persévérance dans son travail et
puis sa technique sa corpulence tout
était réuni pour faire un
bon boucher quoi donc oui aujourd'hui on
est content et je suis très fier de lui
prochaine étape la qualification
régionale pour atteindre la finale
nationale
nous allons continuer à parler boucherie
on s'excuse d'ailleurs pour le gagnant
du concours qui est bien vous allez mon
indiquer
Fabien vous il y a une petite une petite
erreur qui a été rattrapée donc nous
recevons aujourd'hui max the Bodin vous
étiez donc le président du jury de ce de
ce fameux concours vous êtes bien sûr
également bouché tout à fait vous
exercez au chêné
alors un mot sur ce concours donc
qu'est-ce qui a fait le petit plus
qu'est-ce qui donne finalement la
victoire je pense que pour que chacun
des lauréens c'est tout d'abord de
savoir-faire on va essayer de parler un
peu plus fort il y a un
petit bien sûr on a vu selon les
l'apprentissage qu'ils ont effectués
pendant les deux premières années voir
3% peut-être et
donc on a vu le travail effectué dans
leur entreprise ou après c'est le patron
qui qui fait travailler l'élève chez lui
après c'est là où on s'aperçoit que
chacun des employeurs
apprennent mieux que d'autres à
travailler la viande
l'apprentissage donc du coup fait
beaucoup alors le métier de boucherie
attire de plus en plus de jeunes donc on
a quelques données
le syndicat des bouchers donc avant une
hausse de 25% des élèves en centre de
formation sur le CFA de Versailles ils
ont ouvert cette année une deuxième
classe ils ont même eu refuser des
élèves comment on explique cette attrait
tout simplement parce qu'il déjeune qui
ont envie de faire un métier manuel je
pense maintenant parce que scolairement
peut-être qui ne suivent pas forcément
bien donc il est certainement mieux pour
eux de faire un travail de ce de ce type
on se rend compte également que
l'apprentissage finalement aujourd'hui
elle attire tout public confondu pas
forcément des décrocheurs scolaires ça
attire aussi maintenant aujourd'hui
bien sûr parce que vous avez des gens
qui se remettent en cause même un petit
peu plus âgé et qui font ce métier aussi
bon qui n'est pas tout simple au départ
il faut bien le savoir il faut pas nous
dire que tous les métiers manuels sont
faciles mais
il est vrai que pour ces jeunes qui ont
commencé vraiment chez un employeur
c'est ce qu'il y a de mieux
alors par contre il y a très peu de
femmes pour l'instant que ce soit
ensemble de formation ou en exercice il
y en a quelques unes à Paris
mais il est vrai que c'est un métier
quand même assez physique il faut
reconnaître donc c'est pas toujours
évident pour une jeune femme c'est
peut-être l'image également non pas du
tout non c'est surtout physiquement
c'est c'est lourd à porter quoi
vous même quand vous étiez jeune
qu'est-ce que vous a donné envie
d'exercer ce métier
j'ai décidé de faire boucher à l'âge de
15 ans voilà je n'ai j'en suis toujours
dans ce métier et j'ai évolué petit à
petit
le travail de l'avion travail de la
viande il est vrai que dans nos
provinces on a travaillé plus simplement
mais je suis arrivé à Paris deux ans
après mon apprentissage et donc là on a
évolué dans le métier et puis travailler
quelques heures plus que d'habitude pour
pouvoir réussir
alors c'est un secteur qui recrute la
profession avance le chiffre de 4000
postes a pourvoir en France dont 800 en
Île-de-France est-ce que vous-même vous
connaissez des difficultés à recruter
oui parce qu'aujourd'hui
tous les jeunes pensent que c'est un
métier quand même
assez simple alors qu'il ne l'est pas
c'est un métier déjà avant toute chose
faut commencer tôt pour un jeune c'est
7h le matin parce qu'il faut bien qu'il
rentre dans le système professionnel
parce qu'on fait pas ce métier plus tard
je veux dire dans les horaires de la
journée
aux horaires de travail il le faut parce
que sinon il va pas comprendre plus tard
voilà alors un mot justement donc sur
sur la formation 7000 apprentis former
chaque année ça se ça se passe comment
c'est un cap forcément c'est un cap tout
à fait on peut commencer plus jeune mais
l'idéal il est vrai que le cap c'est ce
qu'il y a de mieux parce qu'en général
ils ont 16 ans
et puis ils font saper sur deux ans et
après il passe l'examen ils peuvent
poursuivre poursuivre par un BP
selon le l'envie de
selon l'envie de l'élève
alors le cap est ouvert de 16 à 25 ans
il est quand même possible de se former
à ce métier si on découvre à une passion
sur le tard tout à fait tout à fait
un diplôme et ça c'est également dans
les CFA j'imagine c'est dans les CFA oui
ce sont des classes particulières et ils
apprennent aussi ils vont en cours et
après il y a un examen en fin de cycle
qui correspond
au choix de
ce que l'élève a voulu alors il y a
aujourd'hui 55000 salariés en France
dans ce secteur est-ce que les débouchés
sont finalement uniquement dans des
boucheries à très artisanales qui sont
en tant que patron en tant que salarié
non beaucoup il faut dire que beaucoup
de ces jeunes de ces personnes qui font
ce métier et ensuite ils changent un
petit peu parfois parce que c'est un
métier aussi on fait quand même des
heures il faut reconnaître un petit peu
malgré le
les semaines hebdomadaires qui sont à 39
heures mais parfois le déjeune selon les
les endroits où se trouve vont ailleurs
et point faire aller quelquefois dans
des GMS où ils font moins d'heures
donc finalement plusieurs possibilités
bien merci beaucoup en tout cas d'avoir
été présent sur ce plateau avec nous et
on souhaite bon courage en tout cas à
tous les ans pratiques qui ont passé ce
concours on passe maintenant au dossier
de la semaine
les tablettes tactiles en levant en
poupe aujourd'hui 30 % des foyers
français on serait déjà équipés pour
autant les ordinateurs sont-ils
forcément dépassés nous avons voulu
faire le point avec quelques commerçants
et habitants du département le dossier
de la semaine est signé par Yolaine
Torres Jonathan Wilman et Patrick
Jacques de Dixmude
c'est l'un des produits phares du moment
en fin d'année 2013 près de trois foyers
sur 10 se sont équipés d'une tablette
tactile et c'est assez pratique ça
permet d'avoir un aspect jeu un aspect
éducatif on peut passer des films quand
on part en vacances Alain ça permet de
pouvoir récupérer un minimal les enfants
et puis des connexions internet ça
permet de retourner enfin ça évite de
retourner à chaque fois à l'ordinateur
pour pour avoir des informations ou des
recherches ou voilà le côté pratique
tout a commencé en 2010 lorsque la
marque à la pomme assorti sa première
tablette
pour les CSP+ en fait c'est plus de 300
euros et en fait depuis 2011 on voit
l'arrivée de tablette vraiment premier
prix
donc aujourd'hui on a une premier prix à
49 euros donc ça permet vraiment à ce
produit l'aide d'accéder à beaucoup plus
de foyers et donc c'est pour ça qu'il y
a le gros boom depuis 2011 sur les
tablettes des prix variés et adaptés à
tous types de budget démocratisé alors
l'appareil numérique mais pas seulement
le côté dernier cri favorise aussi les
ventes un effet de mode aussi sur la
tablette n'existait pas sur les PC donc
un PC vous le gardez jusqu'à ce que vous
le PC tombe en panne au lieu sur une
tablette on a envie de nouveautés on a
envie de changer avoir un nouveau look
aussi et c'est vrai que ce marché là est
très renouvelé
l'année dernière dans cette hypermarché
de Maurepas le volume des ventes des
tablettes devant celui des PC en 2012
l'hypermarché a vendu 1700 tablettes et
2400 PC en 2013 la vente de tablettes a
presque doublé tandis que celle des PC
diminue avec près de 1000 exemplaires
vendus en moins par rapport à 2012 un
marché en pleine croissance qui touche
tout type de public y compris les
seniors ici à Voisins-le-Bretonneux un
atelier pour les aider à s'y
familiariser a été mise en place il y a
deux ans j'ai voulu me mettre à
l'informatique pour pour un peu me
mettre au diapason de tout le monde à la
famille tout le monde y était pour moi
je me sentais un peu à l'écart et puis
comme c'est quand même très complexe
enfin tout ça je me suis dit à mon âge
me mettais informatique et tout ça et la
tablette c'est quand même vraiment ce
qu'il y a de plus simple et c'est vrai
que bon bah on l'a acheté au mois de
septembre l'année dernière alors je
maîtrise pas tout mais j'arrive à me
débrouiller suffisamment pour me faire
plaisir
en revanche peine encore à utiliser son
nouvel accessoire elle a décidé de
franchir le pas il y a un peu plus d'un
mois pour lire les mails ça va
et faire une recherche sur internet j'en
ai fait une l'autre jour mais je sais
pas comment j'ai fait alors vite j'ai
pris un papier j'ai tout recopié de A à
Z en règle générale si les seniors
semblent se laisser tenter par ce nouvel
outil d'après Yannick Bigot
l'appréhension des nouvelles
technologies est toujours bien présente
j'étais jusqu'à peser un livre par
rapport au poids de la tablette pour les
voyez c'est pas difficile c'est pas
lourd
on utilise beaucoup l'humour pour les
familiers parce que on a des personnes
qui arrivent quand même dans un état je
dirais relativement angoissé par rapport
aux nouvelles technologies grâce à cette
faculté de toucher un large public les
tablettes font partie des nouvelles
tendances ici dans cette institut
médico-éducatif à carrière sur scène
elle capte aussi l'attention de ses
enfants porteurs de handicap
l'enseignante les utilise pour un
apprentissage scolaire
je trouve que ça apporte beaucoup
d'autonomie au niveau du travail et puis
ça demande quand même une certaine
motricité fine et j'ai remarqué que
grâce à la à la tablette certains
avaient développé cette motricité
motricité fine par le fait de devoir
déplacer des petits objets à l'écran par
exemple la Maël réussi maintenant à
faire seul des puzzles qu'elle avait
beaucoup de mal à faire au début parce
qu'elle avait beaucoup de mal à se
déplacer les petites pièces du puzzle
maintenant ça y est c'est fait on a
essayé mais c'est très difficile parce
qu'il faut réussir à jongler entre le la
souris qu'il faut déplacer avec sa main
tout en regardant l'écran donc c'est
très compliqué de combiner des deux pour
eux on a fait une initiation aussi mais
ce n'était pas convaincant d'après
l'institut d'étude GFK les tablettes
devraient s'écouler à plus de 7 millions
d'exemplaires l'année prochaine soit une
hausse de 21% par rapport à 2013 pour
autant le PC n'est pas mort et son usage
ne semble pas totalement dépasser la
base c'est l'ordinateur pour de pouvoir
le travail ou heure d'Excel enfin
présentation et autres en revanche
l'aspect ludique c'est plus c'est plus
ces tablettes alors pour moi ça reste
encore deux marchés avec deux
utilisations différentes aujourd'hui on
a essayé de faire enfin certains
constructeurs ont essayé de mettre en
place des ce qu'on appelle tablette
hybride donc ces tablettes qui disposent
d'un clavier aujourd'hui ça reste un
marché de niche parce que les gens
savent pas trop l'utilisation est-ce que
c'est pour travailler ce que c'est pour
jouer donc c'est un marché qui ne prend
pas encore mais pour moi c'est de
marcherait qui resteront
en parallèle et ça remplacera pas encore
les PC et pour cause dans cette
hypermarché en termes de chiffres
d'affaires les PC reste devant les
tablettes en 2013 l'outil tactile
rapporte 542000 euros les PC 700000
euros si la tablette revendique un
aspect plus ce loisir pour le travail en
revanche le PC reste toujours l'appareil
le plus prisé comme ici aux
Clayes-sous-Bois ce magasin
d'informatique a ouvert ses portes en
1991 et la plupart de ses clients ce
sont des entreprises
ça c'est l'atelier réparation donc chez
nous on a bon une petite dizaine
d'ateliers donc il nous permet de
réparer entre 100 et 150 machines par
mois depuis son ouverture le marché de
l'informatique a beaucoup évolué il
vendait avant jusqu'à 100 portables par
mois aujourd'hui il en est cool entre 40
et 50 par mois mais on répare presque le
double avant en fait une grande partie
de nos revenus c'était uniquement des
des en fait de la marge liée en fait à
la vente du matériel alors
qu'aujourd'hui on fait beaucoup plus de
de réparation et la réparation déjà
c'est un peu plus porteur et puis ça
permet de pérenniser l'entreprise
d'après lui le marché des
PC ne sera jamais derrière celui des
tablettes par l'investissement principal
des foyers et ne reste pour le moment
qu'un complément
à noter dans l'agenda le concours de la
création et de la jeune entreprise a
débuté mardi il s'agit d'un concours
organisé par la Maison d'entreprise elle
vise à récompenser le dynamisme
économique c'est donc ouvert aux
porteurs de projets ou aux entreprises
créées depuis 2008 sur 50 ans en
Yvelines vous avez jusqu'au 12 avril
pour candidater et il y a tout de même
50.000 euros de gains à se partager et
puis on parlait de la formation en
alternance pour les apprentis bouchées
si vous souhaitez des informations sur
cette enseignement alors que ce soit en
boucherie mais aussi dans tous les
autres domaines possibles audiovisuel
tertiaire ou encore industriel rendez
vous à la Cité des Métiers à Trappes le
18 février de 14 à 17h c'est la fin de
ce fil écho merci d'avoir été avec nous
je vous souhaite une très bonne soirée
et je vous dis à la semaine prochaine